would onsen culture work in the uk
if we had volcanoes yeah you sure yeah i
think so i wouldn't
they serve alcohol you just want you
just want it to work i'll make it work
we'll serve beer not not if people have
to get naked yeah in front of each other
i i think you you underestimate how i
think that culture is like just wouldn't
work in the uk it would not work in a
year if you teach them from a young age
listen
maybe okay but like being naked is
normal yeah you could teach a group of
people cannibalism from a young age and
they'll think it's all right yeah we're
not talking about we're not talking
about if youtube if
like if the entire history of the uk had
changed to introduce its culture from
the beginning because then they'd just
be [ __ ] japan
if you gave them a free beer at the end
of it like you go and make it with your
boys you get a free beer they do it you
sure 100
i i doubt if i if i went up to a guy
from the uk like born and bred never
left the country and i said i'll give
you a beer if you get in this bath with
this other dude naked when you say it
like that that sounds way worse because
that's what a nonsense because they're
probably imagining some type not
traditional bath where they're like
dicks are touching and they're like oh
god oh oh i'm so scared of people i mean
there are our own senses
yeah we don't not really public ones
though oh well i mean we've been in one
have we yeah remember yeah
we've been pretty close together yeah at
the end of the cycling yeah yeah we went
in that really really tight onsen
literally it was like me you joey and
chris and we like our legs were
definitely touching yeah
i don't remember this
that just shows how like used to you you
so weird yeah it's just like nothing to
you yeah
because i'm sure someone who's not used
to that type of culture would find that
true
especially a lot of brits you know
imagine being scared of a penis though i
just couldn't imagine it like i mean
you'd be surprised
like like not not even like not even
being scared of penises but like just
like the social boundary of seeing your
mate's penis yeah or seeing is like
seeing someone close to you and just
knowing what they look like naked i mean
i'm totally fine with it now yeah but
that's that's because i've done it so
that's the thing yeah it's like it it's
that one thing of just like getting to
that point and once you're over it then
you're over it right but i think it's
for a lot of people it stops at getting
to that point
yeah maybe maybe in the uk if it was in
the uk i would think it's weird which is
why for me it's like it's such a shame
because when people from overseas come
to japan for the first time and they're
like i want to know everything about the
culture you know like what are some like
really unique japanese things and of
course the first thing i think of is
onsens right yeah but
immediately i always hesitate being like
i get this
you're about to see my dick
but in like a cool way
i'm
we're in a bath together and yes we're
naked but it's not weird it's not weird
trust me and we're with other random
people as well but it's not weird you
know that's the first thing i tell
people now it's just like you want to
come to japan want me to take you around
we're going to an onsen yeah all right
well i think get that out the way yeah i
think it you know if someone's willing
to go to the onsen with you they're
probably they're probably up for
anything yeah everything japanese
culture yeah i feel like if you if you
can't trial by fire you can't put your
own uh cultural differences aside
to participate in another culture then
uh i don't think you're i agree and and
i and and yeah again like that's what i
kind of use as a gauge of like cultural
understanding for that person it's like
if they can get over this then you'll be
fine i'm very open to some things but
there are some things where i've seen in
like you know when they had like what
was it there's a tv show called like
tribes in the uk there's just a dude who
went around tribes and like the amazon
or something and there was one thing
that he did that i was like okay i don't
think i'd do that and it was
it's like a
penis inverting ceremony or something oh
i've seen that you've seen the video
with the guy like faint yeah yeah yeah
yeah
and i was like yeah you know what i
thought i was up for a lot but i think
that's that's where i'm good yeah yeah
i've seen the one where they have to
like wear that glove of just like bullet
ants yeah oh yeah yeah yeah i'm just
like why would anyone want to do this
because
if i was you know you gave me enough
beers maybe i'd do the answering but
let's go
it's the video of that guy when the guy
like the tribal chief does it to him and
he faints immediately yeah oh god it
sounded terrible yeah just just i think
there are many penises like going ah
yeah i'm pretty much up for anything
that doesn't involve like destroying my
body or pain or yeah stuff like that i'm
pretty much down for anything yeah i'm
i'm usually down for anything when it
comes to like you know especially when
it comes to things like food injury
which is why i hate when people lie to
me about their like make a joke that
like yeah our culture we do this and
then they just lied to me and i didn't
have to put my penis out in public i'm
kidding
this is why i trust my friends in that
when i go somewhere new and they're like
this is what we do here i'm like i trust
you that sounds weird but i trust you
please don't [ __ ] me like god could be
like yeah so in thailand we uh get our
dicks out in restaurants and swing them
around i'd be like all right well okay
[Music]
i would trust god if god told me yeah
right right
yeah you have to spit on the food before
you eat it oh god i'm just waiting for
the perfect opportunity to he's gonna do
it he's gonna [ __ ] do it i know he is
as well that's the word i'm just waiting
for the perfect opportunity to i'm gonna
i'm gonna do because i've only got one
chance to do it too like do it exactly
completely lose that trust in australia
who'll be like yeah you have to snort or
you're out can't be like oh okay
yeah you have to drink alcohol through
your eye
i think
australians do do yeah we do do that
it's called a suicide shot yeah i'm
pretty sure used to have like a lot of
shows in the uk that would like cover
like binge drinking and like clubbing i
don't know why we had tv shows about
this okay yeah and there'd be this one
show and this is where i first
discovered that people did vodka shots
through their eyeball yeah yeah and it
was weird and they would do it and
they'd be like they'd asked them the
interviewer would ask them what'd you do
it's like because i just get drunk so
fast and i'm like is drinking like not
fast enough it's pretty fast and it's
pretty damn instant
it's pretty [ __ ] and then i just
immediately cut to a doctor who was like
yeah well actually you know in certain
any kind of alcohol in your eye is
extremely dangerous and can remove the
lipid layer of uh yeah can permanently
damage and possibly blind you yeah i was
like oh you know i don't need a [ __ ]
professional doctor telling me that like
it should be common sense yeah it's like
it's like sticking a splinter in your
butt it's like i didn't need a doctor to
tell me that that didn't need to go
there
it's weird man
it's so strange because i feel like in
the uk with partying and all that
there's so many stuff that you just do
it because everyone else tells you yeah
yeah
i just always sat there thinking like
what the [ __ ] is going on yeah it's it's
definitely like you especially in
university where you're just gone just
like the the
idea of doing a dirty shot now just like
makes me it makes me feel what is a
dirty shot explain to the viewer's gun
and mix i forgot yeah i don't know what
it is either or a dirty pine you just
like you play probably most of the time
it's [ __ ] ring of fire right right
which is excellent the university game
yeah yeah and then you have this pint
glass in the middle where whenever you
draw a certain card you have to fill it
up with whatever alcohol i feel sorry
whatever alcohol that person is drinking
and sometimes if you're in like an ultra
hardcore party then you fill up with
like other [ __ ] that you would never put
in a [ __ ] drink like [ __ ] like
washing up liquid or stuff like that
yeah they would do it or like tabasco
sauce or yeah like nando's sauce we had
a rule in ours where whoever lost they
had to leave the room for 30 seconds and
anything in the kitchen could be put in
the drink yeah people people would put
like pepper grains washing up liquid and
like they were drinking it i understand
pepper grains are like tabasco but
washing up liquid yeah because you would
immediately throw it up there's no yeah
i've actually done it before when i was
17. you [ __ ] idiot yeah you're
[ __ ] awesome
lucky for some reason during my whole
time at university when i played this
game i never got it yeah well i would
have refused i mean we played that game
but we you know made it stuff that you
could actually drink yeah it's really
nice that's uh that's the civilization i
also i had food poisoning yesterday and
i feel dreadful and hearing this makes
you feel even more dreadful